Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha  Oh, what happens to this guy when he moves to
Heather? It's not like a male, so I don't hesitate to do this regularly because it's a star.
Hey,
try it, it's like Osu
[Music
] It was
[Music]
ni
the voodoo
n ame
Like
Orfs-Erogu's bar is Yoshinabe But I wonder if it's okay.  It's my night when I don't kill the base of lions and hyenas.
[Music]
This guy,
I was so particular about small things that I lost sight of myself.
It ’s not going to happen, it ’
s coming empty.
[Applause]
After all, I ’
m good.
[Music]
Where did he go?